planet sr 388
the infamous home of a startling
discovery
floating organisms known as metroids
hostile by nature they latch on to prey
and leave them drained lifeless do not
underestimate them
the galactic federation dispatched a
team to investigate an infestation so
dangerous it could not be allowed to
survive
we needed a bounty hunter
we got a legend
[Music]
samus's mission is to seek out and
destroy the metroids once and for all
it won't be easy
the planet is a subterraneous labyrinth
of hidden paths
dangerous life forms
and mechanisms rigged for some as yet
undiscovered purpose
effective mapping will be paramount as
will the many upgrades hidden within
this deadly world the morph ball
transforms samus into a rolling spear
the ice beam freezes enemies in midair
the grapple beam allows samus to
traverse difficult terrain
the space jump enables continuous upward
momentum
these upgrades and others synergize with
samus's power suit a highly advanced
suit of armor capable of powering up the
face mounting threats
samus never forgets to expect the
unexpected
[Applause]
samus is the unexpected say hello to the
melee counter
when danger swoops in master this news
timing read your enemy and face your
fears head on and make them fear you
aeon abilities
four incredible new powers against such
terrible odds they could mean the
difference between victory and defeat if
you could find them scan pulse
scan pulse lets you scan environments
for hidden paths
[Music]
lightning armor
lightning armor generates a protective
force field
beam burst beam burst enhances your
cannon's firing rate
phase drift phase drift slows down time
itself
with these abilities to back her up
samus may just stand a chance but they
share a single aeon energy pool that
quickly depletes so use them wisely
[Applause]
an arsenal complete with deadly weaponry
advanced tools
and unparalleled abilities
against the cavernous abyss of vicious
creatures
what nightmares await in the darkest of
depths
not even samus knows for sure
metroid samus returns
[Music]
the special edition includes the game
with a reversible cover and music cd
amiibo
metroid samus returns is compatible with
amiibo figures
tap the new samus aaron amiibo figure
for an aeon reserve tank
which can store aeon energy tap again
after beating the game to access an old
school art gallery
tap the new metroid amiibo figure to
search for nearby metroids
tap again after beating the game to face
the brutally hard fusion mode
[Music]
the super smash brothers series samus
figure adds a missile reserve tank to
your arsenal and the zero suit samus
figure nets you an energy reserve tank
tap these two figures after beating the
game to enjoy concept art and a sound
test